no lineup changes for Terron lose some
thought there might be but he said no
way as urban drives it gets the first
bucket of the game telecast burping
struggle first couple of games last year
and then exploded JR Smith knocks down
the three
his second field goal of the final Leigh
Thompson drills the three point of the
answer into still lost by 19 pedal ears
Durant knocks down a three if suti
efficiency is just off the charts
he's a very good screener James tries to
shoot the gap about junior Smith's and
it may not even be just about as scoring
you're putting bodies on Steph Curry
setting those three games drives inside
off the glass shin that's what left
Curry open from the start Irving's the
Tristan Thompson Smith quick catch and
shoot he said his first two and ran when
the opportunity presented self that's
too good for me hope to run steadily
against LeBron James from downtown for
being just shot prior to this in
transition klay Thompson movement
beautifully without the ball and adjust
his body to back at home
here's Durant Strickland stolen bike em
alone there goes chains one man to beat
goes right in the dream and lays it in
okay push the basketball that's two all
one or one-on-one with the best player
in the world with a full steam ahead
tough to defend didn't want to pick up
two quick ones you got that last game
alley-oop to Duran and he puts it in
like that last possession what I'm
talking about
selective running with coach talked WA
and what a back cut by Durant and
draymond Green
his last two assists have been
spectacular LeBron James drills the
tougher James tour before to start play
Thompson started by Tristan Thompson and
playtime some nails and other Doris
James drives inside and the foul of the
Warriors defense coach he played this
way in the first half and Game two he's
got to continue Smith lost it hurry help
hook it away now types of defending
Kyrie Irving stays with him tough shot
banks at all what a play from Irving
capsule is break all over him James come
on jumper to spin into the game James
pull-up jumper that's good they're gonna
review it
Jean James finds Magee Nikki looking to
post-up stolen by James
James drives hard and throws it down
a steal an attack and a massive
throwdown
I love the attack one-on-one this is
Katie versus LeBron James he tells
JaVale McGee mind your business
pass inside the Curry's double team
finds Livingston Livingston a little
post up boom oh the ball into the post
to green he made the first pass to curry
curry the pass to Livingston hard screen
set on Shumpert curry has love on pulled
back fires a three knocks it down step
curry with his first field goal
Therese finds his face another phrase
Steph Curry from downtown and Golden
State goes up by for LeBron James goes
to the Cinch two threes and a layup now
and they've given up their entire
cushion and down six
and among other offensive trip the shot
clock had been turned off
now obviously yellow a green gets away
and a couple of easy dunks reminiscent
of Game one celebrating and he just
walked away and three thousand owl on
drink more forgets inside and throws it
down
miles Harper off the dribble Tommy hawk
recognizing three draymond Green pass
inside a Thompson shifts to the left
hand gorgeous moved nearly traveled
green inside the David West less is foul
and one and a chance for a three-point
play the basketball good read draymond
Green another outstanding drop-off pass
and David West does the rest and between
them to come back to tire just over two
minutes gone by here in the second James
has been hot early that continues in
another three teams gets a good screen
by Deron Williams the favorable matchup
West gives him some cushion and LeBron
James rises up and knocks it home
less fakes drives runner rolls around
and dropped through James against Durant
inside left-handed still able to make
the play he's got 23 points beats him
along the baseline wrong foot left hand
beautiful reverse layup and grabs the
offensive board late Thompson comes up
with a steal three on one ahead to curry
fires of three plucks it in put it off
with an excellent defensive play and
steal that's their tenth three the first
half Kyrie Irving shake and bake tax at
home to Cleveland played really well in
the first half but those thousand
three-point attempts urban spins drives
layup Oh sensational move from Kyrie
Irving Durant shoots and hits ten points
for Durant
James three mrs. Durant releases down
the other end and finishes and a quick
timeout call by Tehran loo as the
Warriors go up by six big numbers from
their stars James down the lane and lays
it in
look to puffer up to throw that one down
and they're going right back to that
Kevin Durant post up or ISO and Durant
tough shot Jefferson played him well
their experience allow them to make the
pursuit
Irving gets to the paint drives adjusted
banks at home
looks for urban clay Thompson in pursuit
lost the handle
[ __ ] now ahead to curry curry launches
the three bucks it in Steph Curry from
downtown his fourth three-pointer and
it's back up to eight Milan LeBron James
attention warmers comeback in urban
spins urban drive gets inside throws it
up at home as the buzzer sounds
brilliant spike Kyrie Irving allowed
Kyrie Irving to get the basketball back
and uncle drew showing up and showing
house and I think traveling 1 2 3 it's
the NBA you gotta love it appreciate the
move man love quarter three short but I
don't care if that ball goes in or not
to me LeBron James has got to shoot that
ball as they get beat back in transition
you're playing with a championship down
to zip and they push the basketball and
get a wide-open layup Kyrie Irving with
an answer James double jr. Smith finds
some space fires away hexa free
right now greens staying in the game of
the 4000 slides inside at bats and whole
timeout Golden State
edition foul and then the handoff the
turn of the corner and the beautiful
lane James out to Kevin Love steps into
a three that's good
Cavaliers have their first lead in any
quarter besides the first of strugglin
all night long from the perimeter no
hesitation catch rhythm shot curry gets
inside left-handed flips it up and in
and the foul Steph Curry back to the
court turns the corner attacks Kevin
Love the ability to get the contact and
finish with the opposite hand
it comes James Kyrie Irving picks it out
Jo Smith free corner
[Applause]
whose Kyrie Irving flips it up off the
glass and gets it again
bow the perfect angle Irving during what
he did in last year's final struggle the
first couple of games and has been
brilliant here in Game three is klay
Thompson folks up down low
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect fakes spins gets inside pulling
away hurry with a sixth rebound Hydra
Bellaire puts up the three and nails it
to five three pointers for Steph Curry
are in transition great job by Christian
Thompson spreading down it's a way with
a carry hand up so what just a couple of
minutes to pirate ball games inside to
Thompson
Tristan Thompson blocked by McGee curry
comes up with it and then Kyrie Irving
knocks down draymond Green at Val up the
floor and that's been a play that's been
open all series for them and saw Miggy
make the pocket pass you're not gonna
beat the Warriors at those price I think
not clap late types of throws it away
there's James drive stops foul shots
good animal
and James of being a flame maker as a
facilitator and an aggressive score this
time forcing the issue in transition at
the rebound Shaun Livingston little
stutter dribble left handed off the
glass pretty playful Livingston kyrie
irving's momentarily lost it Smith picks
it up finds James Kyle Korver it's good
shot clock at six
good ball denial from Livingston oh what
a pass of another beauty and Jane throws
it down James whips it out the quarter
by revering cuts layup expiry Irving
does it again
how did he make this job and this one
absorbs the contact concentration it
comes Irving Irving till the basket
laughs
a dazzling display for Kyrie Irving
position for guys in blue that's how you
make them say uncle right now with curry
and Durant both on the bench and you
give up transition this is a big time
for both teams dark mark sidestep
massive side stolen by Iguodala
[ __ ] dolla throws it ahead to Thompson
James in pursuit but couldn't get there
as Thompson ant lands awkwardly to back
terrific offensive games he has been
brilliant defensively
Korver lines it up
[Applause]
press with the job that Kevin Levin
doing struggling shooting the basketball
keeping the possessions alive and set a
solid stream david west with authority
[Applause]
Durant drives gets inside layup banks it
home down and make a play look to attack
courage Miz on LeBron James drives past
easily and backs at home James is now
guarding Durant
long Brees Kevin Durant rattles home the
three-pointer gotta get on top of that
screen too easy to go underneath it
that's a layup for Kevin Durant Judy six
steals in the game as well that a huge
impact to spikes shooting poorly this is
an elite defender he beats creates
contact wrong foot 6 foot floater for
foul Durant to Thompson corner three got
it
six three-pointer for klay Thompson he
has 30 running grant Thompson on the
switch Durant drives that's a great
looking finishes that's too easy after
the switch that's too big a gap and too
easy for the great Duran Duran
[Applause]
incredible opportunity Durant for three
it's good Kevin Durant from downtown and
Golden State takes the lead all right
there Kevin Durant those so gifted comes
down and just pulls up and knocks it in
but at the other end they had to get the
two for one and then they had to foul
the moment and hit draymond Green love
to inbound finds James James blocked by
Iguodala ball loose too much data bounds
by James and it's Golden State ball with
ten point four remaining
actually James got away with contact on
the strip buy it without outstanding
defense the best hands in the business
yeah